vadim grinchenko decided early on in  this war that the best way to deal with  the horror is to paint it  he stands in the rubble of village after  village here to capture on canvas the  destruction  and the desolation  [Music]  photos can't express a mood like an  artist can he says  if a picture paints a thousand words  then in his own way he is meticulously  documenting for future generations the  brutal injustice inflicted here but  there's also hope  i also want to show that right next to  the horror there is a future and there  is life  because an artist as a person can  empathize with what's going on and an  artist has a right to feel and a right  to cry  um  his finished work is stark  here he captures what he calls the pain  of borodianka  and the greatest sadness of all is that  he knows he has so much more painting to  do here